[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARU AHUES: My name is Maru.
I'm a developer advocate
working on Instant Apps.
And we're here today to do
an Android Instant Apps Best
Practices Fireside Chat.
It's lots of words.
As you know, we announced
Instant Apps last year
at Google I/O to lots
of developer excitement.
And we're so happy that
we're able to open it today
to all developers.
And in the process
of getting here,
we worked with a large
group of developers
to get all those
nice apps that you
saw in the previous sessions.
Some part of that group
is sitting with me today.
So we have our panel from
CastBox, Twitter, Vimeo,
Deliveroo, and Zillow.
Woo hoo.
So let's get started
with some intros.
First, Alan.
Alan is a product
manager for CastBox.
And he loves
listening to podcasts.
He works on trying to optimize
the listening experience
on podcasts for his users.
Alan, tell me, which ones
are your favorite podcasts?
ALAN TANG: Serial, This
American Life, and especially
99% Invisible.
Because it is made right
here in Oakland, California.
MARU AHUES: Oh, nice, Oakland.
Anyone from Oakland here?
OK, next we have
Lien from Twitter.
And, yeah.
Lien is a senior staff
software engineer for Twitter.
And she works on Periscope.
She was a tech lead for
the Fabric team as well.
And she worked on the
mobile Twitter app.
She likes to hike.
She likes arts and crafts.
And she also likes to
work in the garden.
Lien, let's see, any favorite
spots that you like to hike in?
ALAN TANG: Yeah, so I have
a spot down on the peninsula
called Hidden Villa.
And it has a lot of
beautiful trails.
My favorite runs
alongside this creek.
Its got lots of shade and
gently sloping trails.
So its a perfect hike for
me and my son who's four.
MARU AHUES: Oh, good.
I love Hidden Villa.
It's nice.
Next, we have Kyle.
Kyle from Vimeo.
Kyle, woo ho.
Kyle came here
from New York City.
And he is the Android
lead for the Vimeo app.
He worked both in the creation
of the mobile and the TV apps,
which are both great.
And he loves to travel.
And he told me this
story that I think
he should share with you
guys from his last trip.
KYLE VENN: Yeah,
actually my last trip
I got to bungee jump off
a bridge in Zimbabwe,
which is a ton of fun.
MARU AHUES: How was that?
KYLE VENN: A blast,
exhilarating,
and it was right over a
river so kind of horrifying.
MARU AHUES: Scary.
KYLE VENN: Yeah.
MARU AHUES: Great.
Now we go to Ana.
Ana is from Deliveroo.
She came from London,
a long way here.
Thank you Ana.
Ana works on the consumer
application for the Deliveroo.
She is an Android engineer.
And she loves sweets.
So she has a funny story about
her order history in Deliveroo.
ANA CAPATINA: Yes, so if you
look at my order history,
you will see that I
mainly order sweets.
But I also had a prawn.
Yes, I ordered one prawn.
Because I was showing to my
sister what I was working on.
And I just told her,
no matter what did do,
don't press this button.
And as I was pointing to that
button, I just touched it.
And I placed an order.
MARU AHUES: Someone
got free prawns.
They were probably
a little surprised.
Now we go to--
I know your name.
Lucas.
Lucas from Zillow.
Lucas is a software
engineer on the Zillow team.
And he works on
their mobile app.
He's been at Zillow
for three years.
And Lucas likes to
play games and also
to watch random documentaries
and Netflix and YouTube.
Tell me one, just
one random document.
LUCAS TAKATORI:
So, one documentary
I watched recently on YouTube
was about a Harpy eagle.
It's one of the largest
eagles in the world.
And it's in South America.
And it's really fun to
be able to follow around
a baby Harpy eagle for four
months in a one-hour video.
So that was a lot of fun.
MARU AHUES: Good.
OK, so, what we were trying
to do here is let you
guys get to know us a
little bit before we start.
And now we're going to go
through some questions.
I'm going to ask serious
questions now about the work
that this panel did
on Instant Apps.
Most of it is going
to be very technical.
Some of it's going to be
product questions as well.
And after that, we're going
to open the floor for Q&A.
So we're going to
have two mics that you
can come up and ask questions.
And that will be for
the last 15 minutes.
So don't run off
when we're done, OK?
So we're going to start
with the questions.
First is the why.
So that's the first
question we get, right?
Why would you do this.
So why would you invest
your resources and time
in building this.
So Alan, what made
you decide to build
an Instant App for CastBox?
ALAN TANG: So we took a
risk to try Instant App out.
Because we believe
Instant App is
useful for people
who don't currently
use CastBox to have a first
impression with our platform.
For example, if you listen to
an episode on this American Life
or Planet Money using
CastBox and it blew your mind
and you can't wait
to share it with,
say your friend,
Maru, who happens
not to have the app installed.
So you kick the share
button, send over the link.
With Instant App, Maru
can click the link.
And CastBox will load right away
and start playing the episode
that you think Carol would like.
We get a little bit--
we get some traffic
from search engine
as well if you
search for episodes
that you want to listen and
click the link from the search
results page.
That triggers the Instant
App experience as well.
We actually have a website
with the full functionality
and with over half a
million podcast channels.
We use the website
for internal testing.
Operations team to
validate traffic
or take down some bad traffic.
It's already mobile optimized.
So initially we used WebView
wrapper to try Instant App out.
MARU AHUES: So that
brings a good topic
should you take a website and
put a web wrapper around it
and build an instant app.
When we were working
with CastBox,
we gave him a recommendation
to move away from that
and go with full
native experience.
And I think we gave him this
feedback on a Friday afternoon.
And then they said, sure,
we'll have it ready by Monday.
And I was, like, no.
But tell us a little bit about
what you guys did for them.
ALAN TANG: Right, so if we
take a step back, first of all,
we could see the difference.
So obviously WebView is slower.
The scrolling is less smooth.
We care about our
user experience.
So we actually
don't want our users
to spend too much time on
our user interface, per se.
We actually want them
to come in and listen
to the episode they like.
So internally we
tracked two metrics.
One is total
listening time, which
is about one to two hours
per user per day typically.
Two, the time users
spend on using
the user interface
itself, which we
try to minimize to some extent.
So that's the main
reason we wanted
to move from WebView experience
to the full native experience.
So over the holiday weekend,
the engineering team
did refactoring and
put in the native code,
did testing, and got a
lot of useful feedback
from added from the reparations
team, which is always
responsive and helpful.
We added a few
features such as, we
added a dialog to
pop up the install,
to install the regular app.
For instance, if you
listen to an episode
and you want to
subscribe, the Dialogue
up will pop up and say that you
can subscribe to the channel
by downloading the regular app.
Because we haven't viewed the
full user profile system yet.
We haven't viewed the
full features yet.
The team initially thought
it would be too much work.
But it turns out to be easy.
Because the app was
already modularized.
That sped up the
development process.
We used Dagachu framework
as dependency injection
to build the UI.
We used the ExoPlayer
to handle the playback.
These two libraries together
with many other libraries
are well supported by
the Instant App SDK.
So that made the
development process
fast as straightforward.
As we move on to
iterate the Instant App,
We've had to add other features
as well, such as in-app Billing
for users who want to
share premium content
say to someone who doesn't
have the regular app installed.
So that person can use an app
and in-app Billing to purchase
that content, for example.
So last, but not least, the
journey from WebView to full
native user app cannot be
completed by our hard working
engineering team.
Some of them are
in the audience.
Go team.
And the fantastic support
by the Devereaux team and BD
team of Google.
So I want to say
a big thank you.
MARU AHUES: Thank you.
ALAN TANG: And we're really
excited about Instant App
and as we add more
features in the future
to make the experience
even better for all users
MARU AHUES: Awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah, Alan.
Now, the next question
we get is how long.
How long does this take?
Is this really difficult
or is that easy?
He said it was easy.
Do you believe him?
So now, Lien.
This is your question.
This process takes-- from the
patterns that we worked with,
we saw that it could take
as little as three days
to six weeks.
So we're saying on
average, we think
it can take from
four to six weeks.
It really depends
on how modularized
your app is, so where you are.
So, how long did it take you
to build the Periscope Instant
app?
And what where were the easiest
or hardest things you did?
LIEN MAMITSUKA:
For a Periscope I'd
say it took us about
three weeks total
over a course of
several months to build
a production-ready Instant App.
Periscope was in the
first wave of partners.
And we started development
back in September.
Being in the first
wave of Instant Apps
meant we were getting very
early versions of the SDK.
And we get these
drops every week.
Whenever we got it, we
would test it, build it,
see what issues there
were, and verify bug fixes.
So it was a really iterative
process between Google
and us, a lot of
rinse and repeats.
But by the end of October, we
had a fully functional Instant
App to the point
that it was even
demoed at the Google Playtime
event in SF in November.
And that was really
exciting for us to see.
Because it was just
validation of all the work
that we were putting into the
Instant App and the progress
we were making.
In terms of easiest,
I'd say, there
were two reasons why I felt
like the Periscope Instant App
development was relatively
straightforward.
The first was, the Periscope
Instant App, sorry,
the Periscope app at that
time was already modularized.
So in March of last year,
we had spent a lot of time
pooling out poor playback
functionality from the app
into a library.
And what we were doing
with this library
was bringing this library into
the Twitter for Android app.
Because we wanted to
have a native viewing
experience within the
Twitter for Android app.
So what that meant was
we had a head start here.
When we started the
Instant Apps project,
we didn't have to focus
on modularzing our app.
We could hit the ground
running and really
focus on just integrating
with it and Instant Apps SDK.
The second reason I felt like
the whole process was enjoyable
for us was we just had a
great working relationship
with Google.
And this was super important.
Because we were in that
first wave of Instant
Apps development.
There was very
little documentation.
We were learning as we
are going, both sides.
And our developer
advocate, Arun,
really did a great
job partnering with us
to make sure we were
set up for success.
So we were getting quick
turnaround times on bug issues,
status updates on issues
and how they were tracking.
Google also vetted all
that third party libraries
that we were using.
So we didn't have to worry
about compatibility issues.
They also gave us
tips on what we
can do to reduce or APK size.
And they shared a lot of those
tips at another I/O session
today.
And we got a lot
of testing support.
Again, being in
the first wave, we
had access, or limited
access, to devices.
So we couldn't do a lot
of testing in-house.
And we were also under NDA.
So not a lot of people
knew what we were doing.
So those, I would say,
made it easy for us.
In terms of what
was hardest, I'd
say the hardest thing for
Periscope was just being aware
of the subtle differences
between a regular app
and an Instant App.
So Instant Apps run in
this sandboxed environment.
And what that means
is there is not
a one-to-one mapping
of the API behavior
between the regular app
and the Instant App.
And we saw this
right away when we
were looking at how Periscope
Parts were being rendered.
Periscope Parts are
like a core experience
in the Periscope community.
They're what viewers use to show
their support and appreciation
for what the
broadcaster is showing.
So getting this
experience right,
the Periscope Parts was
really critical for us.
It needed to be exactly the
same between the Instant
App and the regular app.
And the fix for this
was actually easy.
What we were doing was, we
were calling CreateBitmap.
And we were using this
three parameter version
to create this bitmap.
It took in the width, the
height, and the bitmap
configuration.
But in the Instant
App world, you
need to give it a little
bit more information.
So the fix here was we had
to switch to using a four
parameter version.
And that fourth
parameter was one that
took in the display metrics.
And that gave us the density
in compatibility mode in order
to render those
bitmaps correctly
in the Instant App world.
So the key takeaway here is just
to really take a lot of time
to test your app thoroughly.
Because there may be
a subtle difference
in how the API behaves
in Instant Apps.
Because they are running in
this sandbox environment.
They have restrictions and
platform limitations in order
to make it secure for
these Instant Apps
to run on the device.
And Google has come a
long way since we started.
Again, we were first wave.
And the tooling and the
support is really there.
There's a lot of
lent support in there
that will help
developers with this.
MARU AHUES: Yep.
Thank you.
So, we move now to Kyle.
We're going to talk
about refactoring.
Refactoring is, or can
be, the scariest thing
when you read the dox.
And you think, am I going
to be able to do that.
So we wanted to talk about
what it means to refactor.
What are recommendations
that Kyle
can give the audience
in terms of how
to make this process easier.
So Kyle, would you
give the audience
some recommendations on how to
refactor the app, but also how
to reduce the APK size?
KYLE VENN: Yeah absolutely
so the Vimeo app itself,
the full app, actually
started at 16 megabytes.
And to get it down
to an Instant App,
you need to have each
feature be 4 megabytes.
So for us, we were going
to build a player Instant
App that we needed to chop
down a lot of megabytes on.
So with that, we found a lot
of different tools we could use
and different things we could
do to accommodate that and get
there as fast as possible.
One of the-- we kind of started
with the low-hanging fruit
of the easy things.
So of that, you
have a tool that's
built actually right into
Android Studio, which is
for removing unused resources.
So you actually go into
Refactor on Android Studio,
remove unused resources.
And that will kill things
like layout files that aren't
being referenced anymore.
And then because of that, it
will remove any PNG's that
aren't being used anymore.
So that's a really
good place to start.
That's kind of where we began.
The next piece is actually
little bit meatier
and more technical.
And I guess that
advice is basically
trying to look and draw out a
dependency tree for whatever
feature you're trying to
turn into an Instant App.
So what would that end up
looking like is basically
taking the activity
or fragment, and then
look at all the imports
at the top of the file,
and then see what
those point to and what
their dependencies are.
And it actually helps
us to draw this out.
Just so you can see exactly
what classes this feature
will depend on.
So, in our case, we
actually started by--
we thought all along that we
had been modularizing our code,
making it super easy
to just pull out.
All of our player activity was
inside of our player package.
So we started out by just
trying to cut that and paste it
into a module.
So in doing so, we were,
like, oh, hopefully this
is going to work.
But sure enough, it ended
up having a whole bunch
of those red squiggly lines on
all of our import statements,
which was, of course, daunting.
But from there, we kind of
started figuring out, well,
what are the things
that we can cut down on.
What are the dependencies
we can remove
from our player activity.
So what that ended up
looking like, I guess
a concrete example
we ran into, was
we use Fresco for
our image caching,
which if you're
unfamiliar, is actually
a pretty large library.
It's great.
Because it's super performing.
But it's around 2
megabytes, which
in the world of Instant
Apps is absolutely massive.
I mean, it's half of your
requirement for a feature.
So we basically had to find a
way to pull out Fresco and then
swap in some other form
of the image caching.
So what that ended
up looking like was
we created this interface
which handles all
of our image caching for us,
which you then can basically
stub in and inject which
different implementation you'd
like to use.
So the way that we used-- so
basically for our full app,
we use Fresco.
Because we like the performance.
But then for the
Instant App we use
Picasa, which is only a
couple hundred kilobytes,
which, of course, we
still get image caching.
It might not be as fast.
But it still works.
So that was a big piece for us.
The last thing is something
we actually, I think,
kind of did
relatively well, which
was relying pretty
heavily on composition.
So for the player
activity, we, of course,
had this player component
that we rely very heavily
on for all of our playback.
Now our player has to be able to
accommodate 360 video playback.
It has to be able to
do chrome casting.
We have offline playback
of encrypted files for it.
So you can download
to watch later.
And because of
that, we knew we had
to build our player
in such a way
that we could easily
add in these pieces,
or inject them in.
So because we have the
same code base really
for both our mobile apps
and our TV Android app,
we started this process.
Because we didn't
need things like that.
It ended up benefiting
us in the long run using
dependency injection
at that level.
Because then for
our Instant App,
we actually don't
need to have 360.
We don't need Chromecast.
We don't need offline playback.
Because it's not currently
supported by Instant Apps.
So it was actually really easy
just to remove these larger
dependencies.
So with 360, you get things
like the Cardboard SDK,
which is pretty large.
Or with Chromecast you
have Play services,
which is also pretty large.
Offline playback had a whole
bunch of encryptor files.
So we basically were able to
remove those right off the bat.
And that saved us
a ton of space.
So I guess basically just
to sum up all that stuff,
it's really a matter of just
looking at your dependencies,
seeing exactly what
depends on what.
What are the things are
absolutely necessary.
And if there is something
that's relatively large,
think about wrapping
it in an interface.
Try to compose your
different pieces.
With that interface, you
can either potentially
omit it entirely or swap
it for something smaller
like we did with Fresco.
And then also for
people that are
going to be building new
features going forward,
something that we've started
doing and has helped us a ton,
is actually just when you build
a new feature into your app,
build it as a module.
Build it as it's own totally
so it's got a library module
that your main app depends on.
And then keep an eye on
that build.gradle file.
Because that will tell
you exactly all the things
that are consuming
all the space.
And those are things that
can get you in the end.
And, of course, if
anyone has any questions
about our particular
implementation,
you can feel free
to ask me after.
MARU AHUES: Thank you.
KYLE VENN: Of course.
MARU AHUES: Where's [INAUDIBLE]?
[APPLAUSE]
So I think that that's a good
segue into the next question.
Doing some of this work that
you do for your Instant App
may result in benefits
for your installed app,
or your installable app.
So that's like a free
win that you're getting
when you're doing this work.
So Ana, was there any
benefit or did the work
that you did on your Instant
App have any benefits
on your installable app?
ANA CAPATINA: Yes, yes it had.
So when we started to
work on our Instant App,
we knew that we
were going to change
the structure of our project.
This is because
with Instant Apps,
you give users the opportunity
to access a feature
from your application.
And this means it has to
be in a separated module.
So this was one of the biggest
challenges that we faced.
Because we didn't have modules.
And we brainstormed
a lot in order
to find the way to split our
project in meaningful units
that could be used in both the
installed app and the Instant
App.
Because we took
this approach as we
didn't want to have the
feeling in the future
that we are going to maintain
two different applications.
So because it was
such a big change,
we decided to do it gradually.
And as we release
often, we didn't
want to have any impact
on our customers.
So now having more modules,
it increased our build time.
But in the end, we learned
so much during this process,
we have a better
project structure.
And I think with the new tools
that were announced today,
we are going to see
some improvements.
Some of the improvements that
we did in our application
were to reduce the size of the
APK and the number of methods.
And how we did it,
we started by looking
at our [INAUDIBLE]
files just to make
sure we hadn't missed anything.
And then we looked at the
libraries that we used.
And we decided to
remove some of them.
For others we looked
for a lighter version.
And we replaced them.
And then we actually noticed
something interesting.
So while we are investigating
why our resources are so big,
we found out that
some libraries had
lots of things that were
localized in so many languages
that we didn't use
in our application.
So we changed the
Gradle script so
that we can include
only the seven
languages that we support.
And this also decreased
the size of our APK.
So after all these changes,
we noticed a decrease
in our APK size by about 20%.
And other changes that we did
were not necessarily related
to refactoring.
But they were
related to the fact
that we were building
an Instant App.
So one example was, I think,
Smart Lock for Passwords.
This was that a recommended
to have in the Instant App.
And it was very
easy to integrate.
And we felt that it was
a very good feature.
And that we decided to have
it in our installed app
well as it simplified
the sign in experience
for our customers.
And in the end, we have a
great team at Deliveroo.
They are here in the audience.
We are constantly
improving our application.
And during this program,
we learned so many things.
We have now a better
project structure.
We removed some
of the libraries.
We kept only the ones that
were truly helpful for us.
And I would say that the fact
that we decreased the APK size
gave us a big bonus.
MARU AHUES: Mm-hm.
That's good, 20%.
ANA CAPATINA: Yes.
MARU AHUES: That's awesome.
And this is on the installed
app, not the Instant App
so that's good.
Also, yeah, we hear
it all the time
how much tech that
you have on your apps.
And you never have the time.
And you know, it's not a
priority for the product team
to give you time
to work on this.
But now if you work on Instant
Apps and you have the time
to work on some of that clean
up and things that you always
wanted to do, or maybe didn't.
But it's good for your app.
Thank you.
Now we're going to go to Lucas.
And this is our last question
before Q&A. So, Lucas,
now that you've gone through the
process of building an Instant
App for Zillow, what
are some recommendations
or what are the things you wish
you'd known before you started
this process?
LUCAS TAKATORI:
Yeah, so, I think
one of the big recommendations I
would have is to definitely sit
down and read through all the
requirements for Instant Apps.
And make sure that everything
you think you have implemented,
you actually test to make
sure you have implemented.
So for the longest
time, we thought
we had app linking implemented
correctly in our regular app.
The problem was that when we
went to test it to make sure
that it was working, it didn't.
So we had to kind of halt
development on our Instant App
and make sure that we
got app linking actually
working in our main app.
And so, you know, just make sure
that you look all that over.
And, for sure, test
it before you just
start working on Instant Apps.
Another thing to keep in mind is
that network calls and Instant
Apps all have to be
secure network calls.
So we had to go through and
audit our network library
to make sure that
everything we had
was using secure network calls.
And we also had audit all
the third party libraries
we were using.
It turns out one
of our analytics
libraries was using
unsecured network calls.
And then they were
just basically not
working at all on Instant Apps.
So go through it and make sure
that you can either work around
those network calls
in your Instant App
or re-implement those
in a secure way.
Another big thing
that I would recommend
is to get very familiar
with BuildTools
like Kyle recommended,
the APK analyzer.
I think probably
around 70% of our work
was to cut our app size down.
And these tools are
definitely a lifesaver.
Another tool that we
ended up using a lot
was actual Gradle
Dependencies, which
would print out a whole
dependency tree for you.
And it will not only
show you the libraries
that you depend on
but the libraries
that those libraries depend on.
So you can see all your
transitive dependencies.
And you can actually,
through Gradle, you
can exclude some of those
transitive dependencies.
So we were able to exclude
third party analytics libraries.
And that was able to help
cut down the size of our app
quite a bit.
And then another
thing to look out
for size wise are your assets.
Make sure you're not using
really detailed assets when
you can't really
tell the difference.
I think we ended up just
totally removing our two most
detailed folders of assets.
And that ended up helping
to get us actually
down below 4 megs so
that we could actually
get an Instant App up and
running that was working.
And last thing we found
out was we had a crasher
on startup of our Instant App.
And one way that we
were able to debug
it was since Instant Apps are
just a zipped file with feature
module APK's, you
can actually side
load those APK's onto your phone
like you would a regular app.
And that way when
you start it up,
it would start up just
like the regular app would.
And you wouldn't lose
some of these exceptions
in the stack trace.
And I think the last
thing I'd like to say
is that it kind of it
sounds like this might
be a difficult thing to do.
But trust me, it's worth it.
I think it provides a great
experience for our audience.
That's really what
we're all here
to do is provide great
experiences for our customers.
MARU AHUES: Awesome.
Thank you.
If you're interested,
please go g.co/InstantApps.
We're at the Sandbox
office hours.
And you already probably watched
the last session so thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]